la vie pour la plupart des gens c'est
d'aller d'un point a à un point b tout
s'est merveilleusement linéaire moi donc
c'est pas comme ça pourquoi ça ressemble
à ça ma vie depuis six mois on est
séparés avec wendy non c'est pas vrai
vous avez si bien ensemble
savais tu fasses quelque chose parce que
tu vires con las cosas pour la porte
nord est et les enfants boers jours pour
lever new york
ces superbes ingénieur chez j'ai une
nouvelle fois j'ai décidé de partir oui
alors il faut que je raconte les choses
en ordre
bon avant je trouvais que ma vie c'était
pas ça
et là maintenant je me rends compte pas
ma vie avant c'était super simple je
suis senior pas pouvoir vivre à côté mes
enfants que j'ai eus avec une anglaise
qui s'installent ici avec un américain
et un enfant avec deux lesbiennes
tu seras pas obligé d'être un papa au
sens classique du terme
je te connais par coeur font tout a pu
masquer
ma recette si compliqué la ville
sabia n'est pas si compliqué enfin la
mène
moi je vois que je mettais en finale
je pars toujours si l'âme tour allez
quoi je parle plus alors